50% de participation pour une première
élection réussie sans un jeunes
électeurs ont exprimé leur voix la
semaine dernière pour élire leur
représentants au conseil municipal des
jeunes de la verrière 21 conseillers de
11 à 15 ans ont été élus ainsi que 6
suppléants pour le premier CMJ de la
ville ces derniers seront présentés lors
des vœux du maire Alain agent vendredi
18 janvier les jeunes sont une telle
richesse une telle un tel foisonnement
d'idées c'est que on peut pas passer à
côté de ça donc
on pensait que c'était important de leur
permettre de s'exprimer c'est tout jeune
représentant devrait participer à une
première réunion de leurs habits d'élus
dès la fin du mois ça doit être à
l'envers